[Music]
when building apps developers rely on
various cloud services including storage
messaging data analytics and mobile
development as developers expand their
use seamless integration between these
services can be a real challenge Google
cloud functions is a serverless
execution environment for building and
connecting cloud services with cloud
functions you write simple single
purpose functions that are attached to
events emitted from your cloud
infrastructure and services your cloud
function is triggered when an event
being watched is fired cloud events are
things that happen in your cloud
environment these might be things like
changes to data in a database files
added to a storage system or a new
virtual machine instance being created
events occur whether or not you choose
to respond to them you create a response
to an event with a trigger a trigger is
a declaration that you are interested in
a certain event or set of events finding
a function to a trigger allows you to
capture and act on events for more
information on creating triggers and
associating them with your functions see
events and triggers linked below your
code executes sin a fully managed
environment there is no need to
provision any infrastructure or worry
about managing any servers this hands-on
lab shows you how to create deploy and
test a cloud function using Google Cloud
console so what you'll do in this lab is
create a Google cloud function deploy
and test the function view the logs by
the end you will have deployed tested
and viewed the logs of your application
next up on our quest is Google cloud
pub/sub QuickStart console
[Music]